Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous présente sport etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
sport etc on va parler médaille
olympique football féminin maman
sportive et droit à l'image dans le
sport tout de suite le sommaire
les sportifs veulent retrouver la
maîtrise de leur image comment la
question du droit animal est devenu un
élément central dans le sport un vent
nouveau souffle sur le football féminin
nouvel entraîneur nouvel approche
nouvelle communication l'équipe de
France féminine a-t-elle résolu tous ses
problèmes
cinquième nation mondiale voici
l'objectif de la France pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 qu'il soit
considérés comme réalistes ambitieux ou
même démesuré quels sont les moyens mis
en place pour y arriver
[Musique]
pour m'accompagner aujourd'hui Michel
Savin président du groupe sport du Sénat
vous êtes également sénateur les
républicains de l'Isère Vincent Duluc
grand reporter à l'équipe notre
partenaire Maryse évangé P et ancien
athlète aujourd'hui journaliste et
entraîneur d'athlétisme Patrick Chêne
éditorialiste et nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir une invitée exceptionnelle
dont la parole est particulièrement rare
il s'agit de Faiza Amari vous êtes la
présidente de kawjf la société qui gère
les droits de Kylian Mbappé et vous êtes
aussi sa maman et je vous remercie très
sincèrement d'être aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau bonjour à tous les cinq il y a
quelques jours le Paris Saint-Germain
publié une vidéo promotionnelle mettant
en scène quasi exclusivement Kylian
Mbappe en réponse ce dernier publié sur
l'un de ses réseaux sociaux un message
dénonçant l'utilisation inappropriée de
son image la question de l'utilisation
de l'image des sportifs est une question
récurrente et c'est la fiche de sport
etc
[Musique]
Michel Savin on va parler de droit à
l'image est-ce que c'est un sujet sur
lequel vous avez déjà eu
des discussions est-ce que c'est un
sujet que vous avez déjà traité au sein
du Sénat oui c'est un sujet qui fait
partie des éléments de discussion
lorsqu'on doit travailler ce qu'on a
travaillé sur tout ce qui touche à
l'économie du football parce que on voit
bien que que aujourd'hui ça prend pas
importantes dans le fonctionnement des
clubs mais nous aussi au niveau auprès
des joueurs et puis je pense que ce qui
s'est passé récemment dans les communes
du foot avec l'épisode Media Pro on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est une économie
qui qui est en difficulté mais de
l'autre côté aussi dans le même temps on
voit quand même encore des des salaires
qui sont importants et puis cette ce
sujet des des droits à l'image droit à
l'image du joueur professionnel mais
aussi le droit d'image en direction du
club parce que le joueur est même fait
partie d'un club et c'est là où il y a
toute la différence
faire attention à l'équilibre et c'est
tout à fait normal que les joueurs
mettent en avant la qualité de de la
profession mais de l'autre côté il y a
aussi un rendu avec le club qui doit
être équilibré et c'est toute la
difficulté de l'exercice enfin Marie
votre fils a pris une position très
ferme il souhaite je le cite se battre
pour les droits sur l'image individuelle
il était particulièrement en colère
après cette vidéo oui il était en colère
il m'a appelé comme il fait souvent
quand il décide de passer à l'action sur
les réseaux sociaux
il prend quand même le temps d'appeler
deux trois personnes
ma réponse je comprenais son désarroi et
en même temps je vais t'écoute c'est pas
le moment de réagir laisse couler et on
verra après il sera toujours le temps de
rétablir la vérité
ce à quoi il a répondu quand on connaît
Killian non non je veux pas
conséquences il m'a dit je vais les
assumer donc voilà il a fait ce tweet
comme un gamin
qu'il a pas c'était à chaud avec son
cœur avec son coeur parce qu'il est
entier et oui forcément alors là c'était
pas du droit à l'image
parce que la question
il est juste répondu comme un enfant qui
est né avec les réseaux sociaux chacun
sa communication il a fait en ce temps
la question du droit à l'image c'est
déjà posé d'ailleurs alors je suis
repartie dans les dans les livres
d'histoire évidemment le premier exemple
on pas des livres d'histoire j'exagère
un petit peu puisqu'il s'agit de gentil
Ghana il se trouve qu'il trouvait lui
qu'il était sur sollicité avant la le
Mondial 86 et donc il avait menacé de
pas aller jouer avec l'équipe de France
au Mexique
Vincent du Luc vous êtes l'auteur d'un
dictionnaire amoureux du football qui
est savoureux c'est ça existe depuis un
petit moment cette question en tout cas
la question oui de l'individualisation
du droit à l'image par rapport au droit
à l'image collectif effectivement c'est
très vieux alors après parfois c'est
pour un principe parfois c'est pour
l'intérêt le plus vieil exemple que je
connaisse Johan Cruyff en finale de la
Coupe du Monde 74 qui était le seul
joueur avec un maillot seulement à deux
bandes parce qu'il était sous contrat
avec Puma et que les Pays-Bas étaient
sous contrat avec avec Adidas donc
effectivement c'est quelque chose
d'assez vieux aussi en équipe de France
de foot il y avait eu l'épisode des
chaussures
qui était normalement un contrat
collectif avec Adidas et les joueurs
trouvaient que c'était pas assez payé
ils avaient mis du cirage sur les trois
bandes blanches donc voilà il y a
toujours eu des affaires comme ça mais
aujourd'hui les les enjeux sont beaucoup
plus importants déjà pour les chaussures
il y a en équipe de France par exemple
c'est de nouveau enfin c'est
individualisé depuis une quinzaine
d'années environ
mais mais forcément ça pose problème en
deux ou trois joueurs concentre toute
l'attention de
Killian
cette question elle le grecte avait
rendu public le fait que il lors d'un
rassemblement de l'équipe de France en
mars 2022 il n'avait pas voulu prendre
part à une opération marketing c'est
donc quelque chose qui existe en équipe
de France enfin c'est on le découvre pas
aujourd'hui non le découvre pas ce qui
est marrant dans cet épisode mais phasa
la Marie pour expliquer mieux que moi
c'est qu'en fait c'est parti de au début
ça a été lu comme une initiative
individuelle et finalement le reste de
l'équipe très vite c'est dit mais en
fait il a raison il faut qu'il faut
qu'on embray il faut qu'on aille
derrière lui et c'est devenu une action
collective mais qui est partie de
Killian
c'est parti de lui et il a été suivi
oui alors pour expliquer rapidement
pourquoi ce choix de pas descendre parce
que ça pourrait être perçu comme grévist
comme un caprice comme un caprice je
choisis ce que je fais ou je ne fais pas
les droits d'image on en discute avec la
Fédérale avec la FF depuis la Coupe du
Monde 2018
pendant 3 ans on a essayé de trouver un
accord qui ne venait pas puis arrive le
rôle 2021 où il ira de se penalty où on
est éliminé s'en suit plus d'un million
de tweets majoritaires racistes sans
aucun soutien officiel officiel
concernant Kylian donc ça a été un
moment très difficile à vivre et puis
alors le
gâteau c'est le lendemain on se retrouve
dans des supermarchés qu'il y a dans
taille réelle individuel faisant une
publicité il est temps de faire nos
bagages nous rentrons à la maison
ça a été le déclencheur ça a été le
déclencheur je vois le regard de Marie
Evangélique maman aussi Maryse c'est
je souris mais en même temps depuis que
j'écoute tout à l'heure je me dis
j'aimerais pas être super
je pense que ça doit être très difficile
parce qu'effectivement il y a quand même
aussi une opposition mère-enfants
c'est-à-dire que on conseille je trouve
ça fantastique que Kylian
systématiquement appelle sa mère qui est
sa mère mais qui aussi fait partie son
entourage professionnel donc il prend
son avis après ça restait un enfant donc
tu m'as donné ton avis mais je vais
évidemment pas les couilles ça c'est ça
c'est une première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que je pense que j'aurais
été championne à l'époque d'aujourd'hui
tu m'a un peu connu Patrick je répétais
un câble sur ce genre de communication
sans mon avis je pense que c'est
intéressant il y a des athlètes qui
entre guillemets deviennent hystérique
face à ce genre de choses
on a on a on a vu aucun commentaire de
la part de Kylian Mbappe suite à ça il a
gardé pour lui il a digéré
deux choses il aspect financier Vincent
appareil tout à l'heure l'histoire des
chaussures et cetera c'est juste
histoire de contrat moi ce que je vois
aujourd'hui dans l'évolution des
relations entre le marketing et l'homme
c'est très bien illustré par Kylian
parce que Kylian sur le contrôle de sa
mère c'est pas seulement un sportif de
haut niveau il y a quand même une grosse
équipe seulement
un champion Killian il a une identité il
a une réflexion et il a un avenir
donc je pense que quand il voit tout ça
il réagit non seulement par rapport à
ses intérêts financiers mais surtout par
rapport à l'image et c'est là on est
vraiment dans le droit à l'image parce
que souvent ce nom de droit à l'image il
est bafoué parce que droit l'image ce
bidon c'est juste combien alors là
Killian c'est pas combien c'est mon
image on me met dans un supermarché en
taille réelle etc c'est pas donné moi
c'est pas du tout à mon avis ou je me
trompe peut-être
depuis son entrée on ne perçoit aucune
limité décidé 2017 on a demandé à la
fête de donner directement les primes
que qui viennent pouvaient percevoir à
des associations il se trouve qu'ils
n'ont pas pu le faire donc ils nous les
reverse elles sont systématiquement
reversées donc aujourd'hui le droit à
l'image individuelle avec la fédé ce
n'est pas une histoire d'argent c'est
simplement de se dire si on si on vous
conseille notre droit à l'image
individuelle on peut pas quelques temps
après en pâtir voilà et quand par
exemple vous refais vous refusez à titre
individuel un sponsor voilà je vais
prendre les paris en ligne on nous sur
la malle bouffe mais c'est à titre
individuel aujourd'hui on a refusé on a
parfait à la fédé de faire des des des
publicités mais quand nous nous refusons
à titre individuel justement beaucoup
d'argent parce qu'on ne souhaite pas
représenter cette marque mais ce que
fait la marque c'est qu'a fait le tour
elle va à la Féder ou Paris
Saint-Germain parce qu'on voit cette
illustration et là vous vous retrouvez
pour moi cher en plus parce que du coup
ils ont ils payent moins cher qu'avec
nous mais là vous en avez pas mais vous
en avez cinq donc la difficulté c'est à
quel moment on se protège nous et
forcément on a essayé tant bien que mal
de le faire dans le respect des codes
dans le respect et on se retrouve avec
des images comme ça vous devez quelque
chose au club aussi c'est la
communication collective
individuellement vous avez quand même le
droit de protéger votre image quand on
est à 5 on accepte on les a toujours
fait avec le Paris Saint-Germain la
seule chose c'est quand nous on a refusé
à titre individuel ce qu'on demande au
club ou à la fédé c'est de ne pas être
mis en avant dans les cinq mais derrière
en fait il y a l'image individuelle et
l'image collective collective c'est
l'équipe de France ou le Paris
Saint-Germain il s'est cinq joueurs
minimum
oui alors moi c'est vrai que lorsque
j'ai vu sortir
un peu cette affaire entre guillemets
j'ai pas été très surpris et je me suis
dit mais qu'est-ce qui se passe parce
que autant je peux comprendre que votre
réaction et la réaction du jour et de
l'entourage sur des publicités sibées
dans des magasins hot là c'était quand
même c'était un message du club qui
était porté et ça me surprenait pas que
le la star de l'équipe face à promotion
pour
là vous êtes en train de revenir
et moi je me suis dit mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe que souvent on voit des clubs
qui mettent en avant leur star pour
parce que c'est des stars qui font
vendre des places et des stars qui font
vendre des maillots c'est les stars qui
qui tirent les droits TV et autres donc
je me suis dit le PSG pour lancer sa
saison prochaine mais en avance celui
qui est la tête d'affiche du club donc
et c'est pour ça que c'était
impressionnant alors
ça fait après on nous a prévenu de la
captation d'image vous ne savez pas à
quoi ça servait sauf qu'il y a un pote
Killian l'argument qui l'avance c'est le
positionnement dans ce vestiaire
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes une équipe et
qui a 25 joueurs et qu'après le
positionnement par rapport aux individus
des fois la seule star dans ce vestiaire
non et qu'il a pas forcément envie de
porter quelque chose
c'est le PSG sera toujours le PSG que
qu'il vienne reste ou qu'il y a une part
les hommes passent mais le club reste et
c'est pareil pour la fédé maintenant
s'il avait été à 5 avec là il est mis à
ce moment-là avec trois jeunes et tant
mieux pour l'identité après avec le PSG
c'est rentré dans leur très rapidement
et il y a pas eu de conflit particulier
ce que je trouve délicat aujourd'hui et
je reviens sur l'histoire des sponsors
et des sponsors de la fédé des droits
c'est que on arrive dans une période en
fait on demande de plus en plus à des
sportifs et à des stars donc de porter
certaines valeurs en leur demande de
s'exprimer aussi de préférence sur des
sujets pas trop polémiques sur les
autres on veut pas les entendre mais en
même temps quelque part on leur refuse
une certaine individualité au seul
propos qui sont employés donc qui
tuaient employés tu sers un club donc
humainement chacun si tous les employés
qui regardent cette émission si on les
utilise en
utilise leur image pour des marques qui
sont contre leur ça peut être leur
valeur c'est quand même un vrai problème
alors je pense que il y a forcément un
compromis et le compromis passe par la
vie
en tant que maman pour le coup je pense
que j'aurais peut-être passé un savon à
mon fils ou à ma fille lui dire va déjà
discuter va régler tes problèmes en
interne va discuter avec ton avec ton
public donc c'était déjà dans l'espace
public
j'aimerais une question très précise en
fait on parlait de cette utilisation de
l'image si demain un sponsor collectif
de l'équipe de France de l'équipe de
France ou n'importe quelle équipe
d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas une
question qui concerne Killian Mbappe
s'il y a un sponsor je sais de la des
cigarettes électroniques ou quelque
chose qui a la limite de la légalité
est-ce que et je m'adresse à tout le
monde est-ce que on peut utiliser
l'image d'un joueur vu qu'on en met cinq
c'est une image collective même si c'est
complètement contre les valeurs de du
joueur aujourd'hui oui ils peuvent le
faire bien sûr on est d'accord que
Michel Savin on est d'accord que c'est
en fait c'est inouïe comme situation
date d'une dizaine d'années c'est que
vous devez être 5 sur un même support
aujourd'hui on l'a vu sur le paris en
ligne c'est plus 5 joueurs sur un
support c'est 5 affiches individuels
d'un joueur
ah oui là c'est une lecture
végétarien qui se retrouve dans une pub
pour la viande interne juridiquement je
pense qu'il y a rien à faire s'il est
parmi les 5 il est contrastes sous-signé
on est cinq c'est pas individuel là je
pense quand même comme toi que la
discussion peut avoir lieu quand même
entre le dirigeant et le joueur surtout
la Fédération dépend à ce point
économiquement de l'équipe de France
contenu du fait que l'équipe de France
dépend à ce point de quelques stars qui
portent son image il semble que un début
de discussion sur les associations de
marque et d'images et minimum
aujourd'hui il y a eu il y a une
décision très importante en Angleterre
c'est que les clubs de Première League
collectivement ont décidé qu'ils
aborderaient plus sur les maillots les
publicités sur les paris en ligne donc
ça monte qu'il peut y avoir une
réflexion et une décision collective par
rapport à ces sujets là d'ailleurs ça
c'est une vraie c'est une vraie question
Michel Savin cette question des des
paris sportifs de la façon dont on en
fait la publicité
je je si j'étais mère de famille je me
dirais que de voir des joueurs notamment
des grands joueurs de l'équipe de France
du Paris-Saint-Germain de l'Olympique de
Marseille des grands joueurs qui font la
publicité des paris en ligne il y a
quand même quelque chose qui me qui
m'interpelle et objectivement qui me
dérange oui non mais les parents en
ligne alors soit on les autorise sur les
on les interdit ils sont aujourd'hui
autorisés on peut les encadrer mais ça a
été déjà sur des publicités qui ont été
retirées
je pense que vous pensez à cette
campagne absolument inacceptable
voilà mettre la daronne on utilisait un
langage qui est qui
est un certain temps il a fallu que il y
ait une montée au créneau de différence
institutions pour faire retirer cette
publicité mais je pense qu'au niveau de
du sport c'est la même chose il faut
qu'on soit très vigilant et s'il le faut
au niveau législatif si il y a besoin de
de recadrer des choses et de modifier
les choses pourquoi pas mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une économie quand
même qui est importante qui font
importants qui soient amenés dans le
milieu du foot et on voit bien que tout
ça et tous sont dépendants les clubs
aujourd'hui sont très dépendants de ces
publicités de ces
il peut y avoir comme exactement mais
c'est toute la réflexion qu'on doit
avoir jusqu'où on doit aller quand on
voit le déficit des clubs qui sont
accumulés chaque année les clubs
professionnels mais ça compte on
continue comme si rien n'était chaque
année on refait signé les contrats et
des publicités qui sont qui
comment vont les courte qui fait des
comptes qui donnent qui donnent la
situation des clubs avec plus de 400
millions de dettes cumulées peut-être un
petit manque de courage quand même du
côté de du législateur parce qu'on a
bien eu une époque où le sport était
financé en grande partie par les marques
d'alcool et puis à un moment donné la
loi eva est passée et puis on a plus pu
communiquer sur les dents d'alcool donc
c'est faisable bien sûr
c'est difficile mais c'est faisable
Vincent concernant la Fédération c'est
vrai que on s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la Fédération dans le sens où c'est une
qui subventionne les 19 autres équipes
et donc de l'argent il y en a besoin et
aujourd'hui notre idée c'est pas de dire
d'être en opposition c'est de se dire ok
on a la chance d'avoir ce qu'il y a
qui génère qui qui inspirant comment on
peut travailler ensemble pour justement
augmenter les revenus de la Fédération
tout en restant en adéquation avec ce
qu'on souhaite transmettre est-ce qu'on
souhaite représenté donc il y a Mbappé
pouvait devenir un aimant pour ce qui
l'est déjà pour les sponsors de l'équipe
de France et que et quelque part c'est
j'utilise une expression comme on a
l'habitude d'utiliser en politique c'est
du win-win
nous on fait des on gagne rien enfin ce
qu'on gagne c'est pour la fédé c'est à
dire que et je serai la plus heureuse de
me dire que la fedème multiplication
budget par 3 parce que derrière ça
voudra dire que les clubs on récupère
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
c'est deux entités qui travaillent
chacun de son côté et on arrive à ce
point on est arrivé à ce point de
rupture au mois de mars les discussions
ont repris avec le nouveau président et
j'espère très rapidement qu'on trouvera
un accord dans l'intérêt de tous parce
que c'est ça fait du bien personne ni à
nous parce que c'est
une clarté absolue
c'est le temps c'est parfait ça devrait
être pour le foot amateur c'est pas
toujours le cas puisque la dernière
grande décision de la fédé depuis deux
ans
nationaux des divisé par deux en fait au
contraire c'est sur les sur les sur le
dos des amateurs que la fédé fait des
économies mais genre ce qu'on a
parenthèse donc on a grandi dans le
secteur associatif et dans le 93 et
qu'aujourd'hui voilà on aimerait que ces
gamins là grâce à cette de France
riche de culture on puisse
donner un peu plus que du matériel mais
aussi des moyens humains et c'est grâce
à cette équipe et cette génération qui
arrive elle est extraordinaire et
faisons les choses bien pour que tout le
monde soit content et tout le monde
voilà on avance dans le même chemin et
c'est pas forcément le cas depuis
quelques temps donc il fallait passer
par
cette bêtise
dans le mode de communication et dans le
fait une mère a toujours envie de
protéger son enfant
qui parle c'est aussi sa présidente de
société de droit à l'image et quand je
vois les dérives alors oui on a nos
valeurs elles sont ce qu'elles sont
peut-être que vous les partager pas mais
en tout cas c'est les notes et chacun
d'entre nous ici présents défend son
image comme il l'entend à partir du
moment où je n'empiète pas sur la fédé
c'est à dire qu'on a toujours respecté
les codes de la fédé et si il n'est pas
descendu en 2022 il aurait pu descendre
en 2000 ne pas descendre en 2019-2020
2021 on avait toujours cette culpabilité
de dire non on va pas occuper la scène
et quand on n'est pas descendu c'est
qu'après cet épisode du supermarché en
contact on contacte communication par
rapport au club je parlais
dans l'ordre
moi aussi je vais défendre mes valeurs
on va parler foot féminin maintenant
parce que on a à la tête de l'équipe de
France féminine un nouveau sélectionneur
il y a une nouvelle communication on a
l'impression qu'il y a quand même
quelque chose qui a changé un vendre
nouveau peut-être qui souffle sur cette
équipe de France féminine à moins de 100
jours de la Coupe du monde et c'est la
prolongation de sport etc
[Musique]
l'équipe de France féminine a remporté
deux victoires rassurantes en vue de la
Coupe du Monde la Coupe du Monde
féminine qui se déroulera du 20 juillet
prochain au 20 août c'est en Australie
en Nouvelle-Zélande le nouvel le nouveau
sélectionneur c'est Hervé Renard c'est
un entraîneur globe-trotter il a déjà
participé à deux Coupes du Monde
masculines il a gagné deux Coupes
d'Afrique des nations avec la Zambie et
la coupe d'Ivoire il a expliqué son
choix de rejoindre l'équipe de France
féminine un choix qu'on peut qualifier
de surprenant on en parle après l'avoir
écouté
c'est une question de challenge
il y a rien qui remplace les grandes
compétitions dans notre métier
plutôt que de faire des qualifications
qui s'éternisent et qui qui dure très
longtemps donc là on est servi puisque
dans dans quelques semaines cette Coupe
du Monde l'année prochaine les Jeux
Olympiques qui plus est dans notre pays
nous français donc je pense que il y a
pas meilleur explications que celle-ci
pour pour comprendre mon choix
c'est une belle déclaration d'amour à
l'équipe de France les évangiles oui oui
tout à fait et puis surtout je crois que
c'est un beau challenge j'ai entendu
tout un tas de débats sur le fait que
est-ce que c'était dégradé que d'aller
entraîner des filles après avoir
entraîné des garçons en on a entendu ce
mot déclassement des classements il est
entraîneur de l'équipe de France je
pense que c'est un vrai champagne parce
qu'effectivement les échéances elles
sont belles et elles sont fortes et
elles sont difficiles parce que jusque
jusqu'ici l'équipe de France féminine a
toujours échoué aux portes de du podium
a été loin dans des coupes du monde on
peut pas on peut pas dire le contraire
mais il manque l'action d'éclat donc
c'est clair que quand on va chercher
quelqu'un qui a déjà un beau passé qui a
réussi à mettre en action des équipes
qui n'étaient pas forcément facile à
manager un petit peu partout en Afrique
et qui a eu des très beaux résultats et
qui a eu la saison qui vient d'avoir
tout le monde se tourne vers lui en
disant toi tu es censé réussir donc
c'est quand même une grosse grosse
pression je trouve
vous avez entendu des classements mais
l'essentiel c'est que vous l'ayez pas lu
enfin non
je trouve au contraire enfin ça montre
que le monde change un peu parce que
jusque là juste quand même un an ou deux
on partait du principe que les
entraîneurs qui n'étaient pas assez bons
pour entraîner les gars il pouvait bien
entraîner les filles c'était comme ça
les choix des clubs reposer là-dessus
donc c'était quand même extrêmement
choquant donc là je sais que les choses
de l'équipe de France sont quand même
assez curieuses flattées intéressées de
voir qu'un entraîneur de réputé comme
enfin entraîneur de Galles accepte de
venir entraîner les filles donc ça c'est
assez intéressant mais au-delà de ça
surtout il est prêt il est prêt à
défendre la défendre la cause et je
pense le plus grand défaut de Corinne
diacre qui était la sélectionneuse
précédente c'était de pas avoir voulu
porter cette cause de pas avoir voulu se
faire le porte drapeau du foot féminin
et d'avoir laissé passer la chance de la
Coupe du Monde 2019 en France alors
qu'on aurait dû basculer là et là
aujourd'hui on est en train de basculer
au niveau de l'organisation
professionnelle de le foot féminin
puisque aujourd'hui a été annoncé la
création c'était jeudi dernier
effectivement et d'une deuxième division
professionnelle mais il était il était
temps que ça vienne on est en retard
parce qu'elle Italie l'Espagne
l'Angleterre et l'Allemagne l'ont déjà
fait alors Vincent fait allusion à
Corinne DIAC je pense que c'est aussi
une évolution incroyable des relations
alors en parlant sport société c'est que
des cheveux sont capables de virer
l'entraîneur je pense pas que ce soit
arrivé souvent aussi affiché non
[Rires]
c'est la fin du monde c'est incroyable
d'habitude il y a des couloirs des
bruits de couloirs
ça serait pas possible parce que quand
il y a les bruits de couloir chez les
femmes quand ça discute ça discute on
les a pas écouté et il a fallu ce coup
d'éclat
non mais surtout je trouve que le putsch
est un tout petit peu légitime c'est
qu'en fait la culture des filles qui
jouent au foot depuis longtemps et qui
cherchent à rendre ça professionnel en
France c'est de se battre pour la
reconnaissance et c'est de se battre
pour avoir des moyens auxquels elles ont
jamais eu accès donc en fait se battre
aussi pour changer de sélectionneur ça
rentre un peu dans logique de ce
combat-là oui alors que chez les gars ça
aurait été vécu jusqu'au ma caprice ou
un pouce politique là où je trouve que
c'est un sens un peu différente
quand on regarde un petit peu moi je
suis énormément sur les réseaux sociaux
donc je regarde les réactions il y a
encore beaucoup de personnes qui
comprennent pas on est encore pour une
partie des gens dans l'état d'esprit de
elle devrait déjà être contente en gros
c'est inadmissible qu'elle fasse virer
leur entraîneur mais je trouve ça
effectivement très fort à un moment
donné de dire bon on est quand même
actrice on est sur le terrain à un
moment donné peut-être aussi qu'on a le
droit en tant qu'actrice d'exprimer non
pas un désaccord c'est même pas la
personne mais sur une organisation
globale dont on ne peut justement dans
l'organisation il y a quelque chose qui
vous a peut-être interpellé si vous avez
vu les images de l'arrivée des joueuses
à Clairefontaine qui est le centre
d'entraînement de l'équipe de France
c'est que les joueuses une joueuse est
arrivée avec sa petite Marianne de 9
mois dans les bras c'est Amel Majri la
milieu de terrain de l'Olympique
Lyonnais c'est une première en équipe de
France mais je tiens à souligner que
c'est une première par choix des joueurs
que cette option avait déjà été proposée
par Corinne diacre notamment à la
gardienne Manon Haye qui était qui avait
décliné cette cette proposition Vincent
Duluc on peut imaginer la même chose
chez les chez les hommes pour Clément
pour que le monde change vraiment il
faudrait pas que ça soit que les que les
que les joueuses qui gardent les enfants
il y a un moment faudra bien que ça soit
les joueurs bon on en est pas encore là
mais cette normalisation là qui vient de
qui vient qui vient des États-Unis parce
que c'est toujours elle qui sont un peu
en avance sur le côté de la de la parité
ou de la tendance mais en tout cas vers
l'égalité
on en est loin mais c'est une symbolique
importante
qui doit s'occuper de sa fille alors
exactement moi et c'est quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui c'est quand même
quelque chose qui me dérange
c'est-à-dire que là le papa de cette
petite Mariam Amel Majri l'a dit son
bébé lui manque donc en fait les femmes
elles vont travailler mais faut quand
même qu'elle garde les enfants dans le
monde du cinéma c'est pareil les
actrices qui viennent avec leurs bébés
c'est très fréquent je pense pas connu
un acteur qui vient sur un tournage avec
son bébé on a du boulot quoi ça se passe
comment
[Rires]
mais pourquoi pas il faut bien les
garder non mais cette question
qui ont des enfants en bas âge mais non
non on n'a pas encore les enfants juste
revenir sur sur l'épisode de nouvel
entraîneur de l'équipe de France
féminine vous avez tout à fait raison et
d'autant plus que son parcours est
souvent en équipe nationale en équipe
nationale donc c'est aussi un crédit
supplémentaire c'est pas avec quelqu'un
qui a qui a entraîné des clubs il a
l'essentiel de sa carrière ce
là on touche quand même à une des
limites de du sport à la télévision de
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui l'offre et la demande
lorsqu'on voit
encore une fois je reviens sur ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure les difficultés
on va voir ce qui va se passer pour le
sport professionnel avec la Ligue qui va
lancer son appel d'offres
la société commerciale qui va lancer son
appel d'offres en automne pour les
droits TV pour la Ligue 1 on va voir ce
qui est le résultat avec un enjeu que
même qui n'est pas neutre c'est c'est le
devenir même de l'économie même du foot
en France on voit que malheureusement
pour les filles mais c'est vrai pour le
foot comme pour d'autres sports parce
que vous parlez du sport du foot
l'équipe de France féminine tous les
autres sports le basket le volet et
autres les difficultés à avoir à être
retransmis même lorsqu'ils arrivent à
des compétitions en demi-finales au
final de grands championnats d'Europe ou
du monde on voit toutes les difficultés
à pour être retransmis à la télévision
et je crois que là aussi c'est un vrai
problème alors
depuis longtemps on essaye de de
retravailler sur les compétitions qui
devraient être au moins mais oui on a bu
une discussion hier en commission on
évoquait le fait que même pour le
Tournoi des six nations prochainement si
les matchs de l'équipe de France vont
être encore protégés les autres matchs
vont être diffusés risques d'être
diffusé sur des chaînes privées et
captées donc crypté donc on voit bien la
difficulté qu'on a devant nous oui ce
qui m'étonne c'est une équipe féminine
et de la Fédée de l'équipe de France
donc on se dit certes elles sont on est
en retard parce que c'est récent et mais
qu'on puisse profiter aussi de cette
notoriété des garçons pour pouvoir un
moment donné se dire bah celui qui
achètera les droits des garçons achètera
aussi celui des filles et parce que pour
notre nos filles nos petites heures la
nièce c'est important que le football
féminin soit diffusé et et si on ne peut
pas notre service public
la direction des sports français que
j'ai assumé pendant quelques années
lorsque j'achetais Roland-Garros Roland
Garros me fourguin pardon bercer je
pense que TF1 la fédé dirait bon on va
continuer un peu sur les garçons mais
vous prenez une fille ce serait de bonne
guerre quand même surtout que la Coupe
du Monde 2019 qui avait fait des
audiences absolument alors là
voilà il y a une question de décalage
horaire
cette idée de si vous achetez les droits
de la Coupe du Monde des garçons vous
achetez également les droits de la Coupe
du Monde des femmes qu'on a pas de
problème à diffuser un match de U17 non
ça reste des enfants et on les on les
expose on verra ce match donc est-ce
qu'on verra cette Coupe du monde en
clair pas en clair en clair la finale on
la verra forcément va-t-on toujours vers
plus de sport payant à la télévision
c'est le hors-jeu de sport etc
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours France Télévisions
se réjouissait du nouveau contrat qui
lui permettra de diffuser le tournoi de
tennis de Roland-Garros en 2027 alors
excellente nouvelle pour les fans de
tennis et pour ceux qui ont comme moi eu
l'habitude de réaliser leurs examens
devant ce tournoi mais il y a quand même
un petit bémol c'est que comme c'est le
cas depuis deux ans Amazon Prime
diffusera les matchs du soir la night
session le moment où son programmé les
plus belles affiches
c'est le cas jusqu'en 2027 pourtant la
présidente de France Télévisions
Delphine Ernotte s'exprimer comme cela
au micro d'Europe en janvier dernier
peut-être songer et ça on a les moyens
législatifs pour le faire à ce que bien
on impose d'une certaine manière la
gratuité sur beaucoup plus de rencontres
sur beaucoup plus de grands événements
les députés de la nation peuvent
s'emparer de ce sujet moi je pousse
beaucoup à ça après il y aura peut-être
une répartition entre TF1 M6 évidemment
France Télévisions mais mais surtout il
faut se défendre de cette privatisation
du sport c'est ça qui m'avait fait
m'avait rendu furieuse au moment du
match de Roland-Garros l'année dernière
puisqu'il était sur Amazon et donc voilà
il fallait avoir un abonnement prime
même s'ils ont dit que c'était gratuit
en fait fallait quand même donner sa
carte bleue enfin bref c'était pas
c'était pas si gratuit que ça donc
Delphine va continuer à être furieuse
mais est-ce qu'on peut vraiment faire
quelque chose Michel ça va
on voit bien toute ambiguïté d'un côté
ce discours qui est très sympathique et
qui peut partager par un grand nombre de
voir le plus grand nombre de rencontres
en clair et puis le côté il y a une
économie et l'économie du sport
professionnel qui aujourd'hui court
après les contrats les plus importants
tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué
le fait que même aujourd'hui au rugby
qui est encore protégé on évoque la
possibilité de voir les certains matchs
du Tournoi des six nations hors d'équipe
de France sur des chaînes cryptées on
voit ce qui s'est passé à Roland-Garros
on va voir un petit peu aussi le ce qui
va se passer avec la société commerciale
qui va essayer d'étendre ses droits à
l'international pour la Ligue 1 mais
tout ça ce que d'ailleurs il y a des il
y a des sommes considérables qui sont en
jeu et qui font vivre le sport
professionnel en France alors soit on
veut revoir les choses à la baisse en
termes de fonctionnement au niveau du
sport professionnel en France et avoir
moins besoin d'argent et donc là il y a
peut-être c'est possible c'est un retour
en arrière que personne ne veut parce
que d'ailleurs ça il y a
ce flambeau donc on voit bien qu'il faut
arriver à trouver le bon équilibre pour
maintenir et protéger certaines
diffusions des matchs les plus
importants notamment des équipes de
France et des grands championnats des
grands pour moi sur sur les chaînes en
clair et puis et puis essayer de réguler
à la castérale la ministre des Sports a
déclaré au début du mois de mars quel
travaillait sur une modification du
décret c'est un décret qui date de 2004
qui définit les 21 événements majeurs
qui devraient être diffusés en clair le
sport gratuit
en participer à la rédaction de cette
loi la première le décret de 2004
suite est revenu là-dessus avec je tiens
celui de Charles Biétry qui était à
Canal et moi patron de sport français ça
a été un barman pas possible et je pense
que ça a été une belle réussite de
protéger c'est final ces grands
événements aller plus loin je n'y crois
pas une seule seconde dans la réalité
économique du sport aujourd'hui
le service public retransmettait toutes
les manifestations sans coupure
publicitaire on faisait 6 heures
d'étapes du Tour de France on mettait
pas maintenant de la pub dans la montée
de l'Alpe d'Huez
moi je trouve encore presque miraculeux
j'ai bien dit il y a moins que la France
propose autant de grands événements en
clair et en gratuit on va pas vers une
évolution pardon monsieur sénateur ou
les législateurs vont prendre les choses
normales
de Ligue des Champions où on était sur
une devant une chaîne en clair pour le
plus gros match ça c'est la Ligue des
Champions féminine et diffusé sur
Youtube par des n actuellement et moi la
semaine dernière j'ai enfin j'avais vu
les j'ai vu les cartes finales sur
Youtube donc ça oui donc en fait c'est
seulement si le diffuseur accepte de le
passer en clair effectivement par ce
créneau là qu'on le verre en clair tout
le monde ça n'arrivera pas l'autre
difficulté c'est que Amazon Prime ne
diffuse jamais ces chiffres donc on a
absolument aucune idée
justement parce que vous parliez de
l'appel d'offres de l'automne prochain
pour la Ligue 1 masculine on a aucune
idée de combien de personnes regardent
aujourd'hui
la Ligue 1 masculine il va se passer
quoi on part sur quelle base pour ce
pour cet appel d'offres on part en l'air
comme ça en disant sur une base déjà qui
pour moi est bancale c'est-à-dire qu'on
a tourné le dos à un partenaire
historique qui était Canal+ pour pour se
tourner vers un partenaire d'avenir qui
est prime Amazon mais un prix
d'avant-hier donc après donc après ça va
être un peu compliqué je trouve pour
trouver un accord qui soit favorable à
Ligue 1 moi je voilà effectivement
Vincent Labrune a pas mal joué le coup
en cédant autant enfin en levant autant
d'argent elle s'est laissé le de la
société enfin le nouveau partenaire de
la société commerciale mais c'est pas
pour ça que que qu'on va approcher le
milliard pour les droits pour les droits
de la Ligue 1 à l'époque Kyo le milliard
le milliard c'est juste ce qu'il
faudrait éviter de faire mais surtout
qu'il aurait pu avoir un milliard la
dernière fois s'ils avaient pas choisi
média pro ils l'ont même un canal on va
rester sur le parce que vous avez
regardé la
Ligue des Champions féminine sur le
digital et on s'amuse bien sur le
digital on va parler de chat j'ai pété
on était obligé nous aussi de d'essayer
un petit peu un intelligence
artificielle c'est surtout les lèvres en
ce moment alors je voulais vous montrer
le classement que donne chat GPT
le classement des sportifs français
Zinédine Zidane premier jusque là je
pense qu'on est on est peut-être à peu
près tous d'accord je constate quand
même qu'il y a beaucoup de football
puisque le classement c'est Zidane
Platini bon Yannick Noah Tony Parker
Renaud Lavillenie Martin Fourcade Marie
José Pérec Laure Manaudou Sébastien Loeb
Jean-Claude Killy pas beaucoup de femmes
on a que deux femmes
si c'est la synthèse de ce qui se dit de
ce qui s'écrit et c'est inquiétant c'est
un problème et donc dans quelques années
on verra Kylian Mbappé dans le champion
dans le classement des grands champions
c'est un champion
c'est peut-être un classement de du
siècle dernier
tout en haut je vais pas mettre de
carton rouge à chat GPT mais si
l'intelligence artificielle doit me
remplacer un jour sur ce plateau j'ai
quand même envie de donner un carton
rouge aujourd'hui c'est le carton rouge
de sport etc le 6 avril dernier c'était
la journée internationale du sport au
service du développement de la paix
alors visiblement l'information elle a
échappé à certains l'Indonésie s'est vu
retirer par la Fédération internationale
de football l'organisation de la Coupe
du monde des moins de 20 ans pour des
raisons liées au contexte actuel entre
guillemets traduction l'Indonésie
l'entretien aucune relation diplomatique
avec Israël et aucune province
d'Indonésie n'a accepté de recevoir la
délégation israélienne pour la
compétition le président indonésien
avait rappelé l'attachement du pays à la
cause palestinienne tout en rappelant
qu'il ne faut pas mélanger sport et
politique c'est visiblement ce qui a été
fait on ne sait toujours pas où aura
lieu la Coupe du monde des moins de 20
ans la Coupe du monde de football
masculin donc après
la question des athlètes russes et
biélorusses aux Jeux Olympiques la
géopolitique on a l'impression qu'elle
est omniprésente dans dans le sport
Michel Savin
est-ce que c'est un bien ou un mal de
quand même sur le sport doit être quand
même un endroit où on devrait protéger
les compétitions et les athlètes qui
participent parce que tout à tête quel
que soit son origine quel que soit son
pays et lorsqu'il est sain dessin
dessiné dans une dans un sport son rêve
c'est d'aller le plus haut possible dans
les plus grandes compétitions et voilà
donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours des
sujets qui sont qui sont très polémiques
on va voir s'il va se passer sur pour
les jeux de l'année prochaine à Paris
moi j'espère que que ce soit une grande
fête sportive et que le maximum
d'athlètes de l'ensemble des pays du
monde puisse y participer c'est voilà
après bien sûr qu'il y a des enjeux
politiques il y a des enjeux de société
par rapport à ce qui se passe dans
certaines régions de la planète mais
est-ce que c'est les sportifs qui
doivent être les les plus grands
perdants je crois pas footballé
politique c'est quand même des amours
conflictuels depuis un petit moment
Vincent dans le dans le cas de cette
Coupe du Monde de toute façon
historiquement que ça soit en foot ou
enfin pour le foot pour la coupe du
monde de foot tous les jeux olympiques
globalement on est à peu près toujours
aller au à l'endroit où il fallait pas
au moment où il fallait pas donc c'est
quand même
c'est quand même assez ancien que la
France
tout le mouvement
occidental en faveur de l'Ukraine et
contre la Russie va se heurter au moment
du fin des Jeux Olympiques à l'idée que
dans le monde tout le monde n'a pas la
même notion du camp de l'agresseur et du
camp des agresser et qui a d'autres
conflits dans le monde et que ça crée
une jurisprudence qui est sur le long
terme probablement intenable et là on
est au cœur de cette jurisprudence et on
sait pas comment comment ces jeux vont
voir lieu quel boycotte aura lieu enfin
voilà c'est très difficile
mais moi je trouve cette vision un petit
peu angélique je suis pas là pour dire
il faut aucune athlète d'origine russe
biélorus au jeu c'est pas moins de
décider en revanche vous avez
aujourd'hui des sociétés commerciales
qui payent très charmant la position
occidentale par rapport à la Russie vous
avez des gens qui sont au chômage parce
qu'il y a plus de carnet de commandes
qui viennent de la Russie donc moi je
n'aime pas trop isolé le sport de tout
cela en disant les pauvres sportives ils
se sont préparés ils sont russes mais
c'est pas de leur faute je pense que le
power en politique et en sport il existe
donc la manière dont vont être récupérés
les performances des Russes s'ils
viennent sous une bannière neutre la
manière dont ça va être récupéré par le
pouvoir russe on sait comment ça va se
passer je suis pas en train de dire
qu'il faut pas qu'il vienne non mais
arrêtons avec Angélique en disant les
pauvres petits sports
puisque les équipes peuvent pas
participer aux ex exactement donc déjà
ça réduit
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
vrai ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
Ukraine en Russie il y a d'autres
conflits dans le monde et donc qui
devrait avoir la même position qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire demain si la Chine
continue à avoir des positions aussi
vis-à-vis de Taïwan ça veut dire que
demain on refuse aussi les Chinois donc
voilà on va on va on rentre dans un
système où vous avez tout à fait raison
ça va faire jurisprudence et je vois pas
voilà et moi j'ai envie je l'espère et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde le
Mouvement olympique est français se
mobilise pour la réussite de ces jeux
mais bien entendu justement tout le
monde se mobilise pour la réussite de
ces jeux on va continuer à parler Jeux
Olympiques parce que les célébrations du
j-500 sont terminées à présent le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a sonné la mobilisation générale
et certains commencent à réévaluer les
objectifs en termes de médaille objectif
80 médailles c'est le c'est le score de
sport etc
[Musique]
je vois bien mon plateau que vous me
regardez comme si j'avais perdu la tête
parce que je parle de 80 médailles ça ne
sort pas de mon esprit ambitieux c'est
un objectif qui avait été fixé par Laura
Flessel qui était ministre des Sports
lors de la désignation de Paris 2024
comme ville organisatrice on écoute le
rafle celle insuffler aller chercher une
dynamique avoir un cap c'est 80
médailles avec des acteurs
44 avec une trentaine de places de 5e 6e
7e donc l'idée c'est de travailler
l'exercice
sur le matériel sur la nutrition sur la
santé sur l'accompagnement des sportifs
pour aller chercher ces 80 médailles
qu'on a c'est simple si on organise les
jeux il faut les réussir
bon je vais cette fois je vais y aller
les deux pieds dans le plat 80 médailles
c'est impossible Maryse évangélique je
sais pas si c'est possible si c'est
impossible en tout cas on n'est pas très
bien parti et puis si je me contente me
contente simplement dans mon dans mon
sport pour avoir des médailles
effectivement il faut travailler ce
deuxième niveau dont parler le rafler
selle le deuxième niveau il a été
complètement abandonné alors pas que du
fait de l'organisation ou de la
politique sportive française il y a
aussi le covid qui est passé par là qui
a mis de côté à peu près tous les 2e
niveau qui n'avaient plus accès aux
structures d'entraînement
mais les 80 médailles c'est chez nous
on les attend et si je regarde pas par
rapport à mon sport par exemple je vais
vous donner un simple exemple
il se trouve que l'une des rares salles
dans lequel on peut faire de
l'athlétisme en Île-de-France et en
France donc qui est une salle importante
qui est celle d'Aubonne a été présentée
par l'équipe des États-Unis qui va venir
s'entraîner là ils sont pas faux les
Américains et ils ont eu certaines
exigences mettre la salle avec la une
piste qu'on va avoir au Stade de France
un certain nombre de choses comme ça
mais aussi transformer la salle en salle
de basket ça veut dire qu'à partir
normalement de septembre 2023 les
athlètes n'ont plus de salles en région
parisienne
a également demandé à pouvoir avoir
accès au Stade de France au moins une
fois pour les championnats de France
avant les Jeux Olympiques pour l'instant
c'est impossible alors moi je veux bien
qu'on nous mette 80 médailles sur la
table il va peut-être falloir mettre un
petit peu de moyens derrière et de
volonté pour
ces sportives
absolument peut-être que le pouvoir
politique a compris 80 médailles c'était
un tout petit peu ambitieux puisqu'on
parle maintenant de figuré parmi les
cinq meilleures nations bon clairement
quand on dit parmi les cinq meilleures
nations c'est 5e
non mais enfin objectivement quand on
regarde les classes de Laura qui dit il
faut réussir ses jeux pour moi 2024 les
réussir c'est pas seulement en termes de
ménage c'est les réussir vis-à-vis du
monde sur l'organisation de la sécurité
etc c'est ça réussir les jeux 2024 80
médailles on peut avoir 55 médailles et
faire des jeux formidables donc faut
arrêter avec ces sports
et tout le monde
il faut réussir ses jeux et on a tous
conscience que l'image des jeux il va
passer par la cérémonie d'ouverture et
que ça va tout écraser tout ce qu'on
aura pas fait avant sera balayer par
l'éventuel et j'espère la réussite de ce
jour-là et par l'image forte qui vont
rester mais quand même tous les tous les
grands pays de sport qu'on organisé les
championnats les les Jeux Olympiques ont
profité quand même de ces Jeux
Olympiques pour mettre en place une
politique sportive durable
quand on voit comment le sport
britannique a
est parti un peu grâce au tremplin des
des jeux des Jeux de Londres en 2002
enfin j'allais dire autrement structuré
que notre base et notre histoire
sportive et on a l'impression qu'au
niveau sport on a évolué de rien pas
d'un centimètre grâce au jeu il y a pas
un domaine sportif où les jeux et amener
quoi que ce soit pour l'instant
c'est bien ce qui pose problème on parle
de Michelin
du bouleversement du changement qui peut
y avoir dans le sport et l'éducation
donc le sport à l'école on a beaucoup
parlé le Hortense scolaire les
tentatives qui ont été faites de faire
faire d'avoir des villes tests avec les
gamins qui finissent à 13h et qui vont
dans les structures sportives dans les
structures sportives c'est 90% voire 95%
bénévoles bien placé pour le dire c'est
et donc qui dit bénévole dit que a
priori on n'est pas libre en journée
donc les gamins ils sont libres
l'après-midi mais qui leur fait faire du
sport personne enfin bon il y a beaucoup
de choses juste pour parler de pour
parler de médaille vous vous parliez
justement de la façon dont ça évolue le
sport français c'était 33 médailles à
Tokyo
c'était pas un très bon résultat à Tokyo
donc ça peut faire 34 déjà
on peut compter sur lui mais ça suffit
pas c'est une équipe Vincent Duluc le
football c'est pas seulement qu'il
vienne baper
peut-être quand même avoir un petit
espoir quand même pas sur le nombre de
médailles mais il faut quand même
prendre en compte que alors peut-être un
peu avec un peu de retard vous avez tout
à fait raison mais quand même
des choses ont été mises en place Claude
Nesta a mis en place ambition bleu et le
cercle de loi de performance ou on a
passé autant de temps en polémique que
comme mise en place quand même
globalement on a pris du retard c'est
pour ça que je pense que à titre
personnel je pense pas que les résultats
on les aura pas 2024 mais c'est plutôt
il faut qu'on continue non mais j'en
sens bien mais c'est vrai que le retard
qui a été pris pour la mise en place de
ce suivi de cet accompagnement au niveau
des sportifs de niveau les 400 qui sont
ciblés avec un travail auprès des
fédérations qui je pense ne va pas être
productif pour 2024 mais il doit
s'inscrire dans la durée et je pense que
vous êtes à l'origine d'une lettre
ouverte pour demander la relance du plan
piscine
[Musique]
la tentiassage elle vit aussi en
Seine-Saint-Denis on a beaucoup parlé au
moment de la Coupe du Monde de 98 des
emplois et des logements que ça allait
apporter ça apportait quelques logements
les emplois on les attend toujours donc
du développement économique que ça peut
faire qui est un véritable engouement et
puis ça passe aussi peut-être par une
stabilisation un peu sociale de la
France qui en ce moment est encore même
très agité je pense que les Jeux
Olympiques c'est pas encore la priorité
des Français pour l'instant donc la
réussite elle est bien au-delà des 80
médailles elle est évidemment sur
l'image qu'on va envoyer au monde elle
est aussi sur ce qu'on va réussir à
fédérer c'est pas un peu pour montrer
les muscles politiques moi aussi
pour faire des médailles mais
non moi je pense qu'il y a deux choses
il y a deux choses il y a l'urgence des
Jeux olympiques de la préparation et
vous avez tout à fait raison on l'a bien
vu qu'on avait pris après tout le
résultat de Tokyo a mis en alerte tout
le monde sportif avec 33 médailles et
heureusement que la dernière semaine des
sports collectif ont été pourvoyeur de
d'un nombre de médailles importants
aussi bien chez les filles que chez les
garçons donc tout de suite il y a eu la
prise en compte de cette urgence devant
le retard qui avait été pris et de dire
il faut mettre quelque chose en place
pour préparer et accompagner les
athlètes de la meilleure des façons pour
2024 et puis à côté de ça vous avez la
politique sportive nationale et un des
enjeux aussi de Paris 2024 c'est
l'héritage l'enjeu c'est que les
Français dans tout le pays puissent
pratiquer plus d'activité physique et
sportives que ce soit mais pour ça il
faut une vraie politique nationale
complètement moi j'y crois pas il y a
pas un moment où je crois que l'héritage
il va laisser comme ça
mais j'y crois pas du tout je crois plus
quel héritage en fait non mais logement
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est pas parce que les jeux sont passés
qu'il y aura une heure de sport à
l'école l'après-midi c'est pas parce que
il y a des programmes tous les 5 ans
tous les 5 ans il y a un programme pour
qu'il y a une demi-heure de sport à
l'école donc cette année il y en a un
nouveau c'est sport à l'école on aura
pas plus de salle on aura pas plus de ça
on n'aura pas plus de piscine on aura
plus de rien de rien encore une fois la
plupart des appels d'offres qu'on reçoit
puisque là pour le coup je mets ma
casquette de président de club et
d'entraîneur qu'on reçoit justement pour
pour s'insérer dans cette dynamique de
l'héritage 2024 du une demi-heure de
sport à l'école en plus encore une fois
c'est il y a énormément de de moyens qui
sont mis là dessus en se tourne toujours
vers les mêmes personnes qui sont les
bénévoles et le bénévolat a ses limites
très clairement les bénévoles sont
épuisés aujourd'hui je pense que sur
l'Île-de-France je suis pratiquement
d'abord il y a très peu de présidents de
femmes et il y a quasiment pas de
présidents qui sont pas retraités parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps on peut plus on
est on est cramé complet
à la marie je sais que 2024 c'est loin
mais est-ce qu'on a une chance de voir
qu'il y a Mbappé je veux faire les Jeux
Olympiques une chance je sais pas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il souhaite les faire
après il n'est pas on a il a des il a
des clubs il a une Fédée il y a un euro
juste avant donc je crois qu'on va se
mettre autour de la table on discute
déjà après il est lucide aussi donc
voilà il se peut qu'il soit vraiment
parce qu'il a envie et puis même nous on
dit encouragé maintenant il est pas tout
seul voilà merci beaucoup merci à tous
les 5 merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
un grand merci aux équipes techniques et
éditoriales qui m'aident au quotidien à
préparer cette émission nous on se
retrouve dans un mois pour un nouveau
numéro de sport etc sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous a présenté sport etc